Залагоджувати суперечки, зводити мости,
бути посередником - так функціонує
міжнародна політика. Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр
майже вісім років був головним
дипломатом Німеччини, ставши при цьому
одним з улюблених політиків ФРН.
У листопаді минулого року Штайнмаєра висунули в президенти.
Свою майбутню місію він бачить так.
Федеральний президент не має права
спрощувати. Він повинен задавати настрій.
Я в будь-якому разі хочу розбудити той потенціал,
який ховається в цьому суспільстві.
Я хочу його цінувати, підтримувати.
І до цього я, шановні пані та панове,
докладу всіх зусиль.
Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр - дуже наполеглива людина.
Це допомагає в неспокійні часи, вважає його партійний соратник.
У ці складні часи міжнародний
досвід, який він безперечно має, я вважаю,
дуже потрібен. Тож він правильний чоловік у правильний час.
При цьому його шлях
на політичний Олімп був непростим. Він походить
з маленького містечка Бракельзік у центральній Німеччині,
син столяра, вивчав право,
отримав докторський ступінь, вступив
у Соціал-демократичну партію Німеччини,
познайомився з дружиною - теж юристкою.
І зустрів свого наставника та соратника - Ґергарда
Шредера. Спочатку робив кар'єру
в Нижній Саксонії, потім - коли Шредер став
канцлером - Штайнмаєр прийшов разом з ним
в урядові кабінети. У 2009 році
Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр став кандидатом в канцлери
від соціал-демократів, однак це
увінчалося історичним провалом
на виборах до Бундестагу - СДПН
тоді набрала рекордно низькі 23 відсотки.
Соціал-демократи опиняються в опозиції.
Утім, і тут він проявляє витримку
і дипломатію.
Це й допомогло йому стати головним дипломатом країни.
Тепер Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр
переходить у ще вищу лігу -
у президенти ФРН.